I'm run app I'll be talking on convex
optimization which is optimization for
convex functions on convex sets
so Roger Roger worked with with Boyd and
he's been talking about it for years and
years and I always thought you know I
sort of Roger was starting about convex
optimization I sort of get this picture
of a balloon in my head and and sort of
imagine you know optimizing over blobby
objects and stuff in a sense is what it
is but it's actually a lot more than
that there's a there's a whole a whole
set of things that are available and the
big thing about it before I even get
started is that just as so so when when
they figured out the simplex algorithm
and so linear programming then became a
solved problem in essence and so the
whole wide array of applications open up
for that and basically the same thing is
true for some of these fields of convex
optimization like semi definite
optimization and and some other things
so now we have a much broader thing
which is sort of an essentially solved
problem and so we can access libraries
that will solve problems as long as we
can map into these various forms I'm
going to sort of talk today about some
of those mappings and what we're trying
to do within the Wolfram language to be
able to make that accessible so first
let's define I'm gonna get a little math
e for awhile so bear with me okay so I'm
gonna make some definitions and I'll
talk about what convex optimization is
so so here are a few basic definitions
so a set is a fine if you can add you
know any two elements in a combination
theta plus 1 minus 8 of X and that that
combination is also in the set so a set
is convex if it's a fine with the theta
being greater than 0 but actually
between 0 & 1 okay and a function is
convex if you f of theta X plus 1 minus
a2 y is less than me with theta f of X
plus 1 minus say F of Y ok and another
important definition that I'm going to
use a law take advantage is this thing
called the epigraph the epigraph of
function is a set X T so the X is the
domain and F is actionability
and the epigraph of a convex function is
a convex set and that's sort of how a
lot of this convex optimization stuff
work so let me
oh you know what I can't see huh I'm hm
okay well I had this very nice
manipulate cell for you to show you what
all those things were but it seems to
have disappeared so I don't know what
that's gone but okay so so so here's
here's a big thing about combat
conversation so we'll call the
optimization problem to minimize some
function of X okay and this is just the
classic optimization problem with F you
know so a bunch of constraints with with
functions and some equality constraints
okay and it's going to be called a
convex optimization problem if all the F
f eyes are convex functions and the H
IJ's are affine functions or mainly
they're they're linear functions and
then we then we have what's called a
convex optimization problem and the big
thing or actually the really smallest
thing is that this so for a convex
optimization problem a local minimum is
also global minimum so that's one of the
the huge thing so you don't have to
search around there are no extra bumps
it's got to be a global minimum so so
any convex minimization method is
actually a global minimization method
and that's one of the one of the reasons
these problems can sort of be considered
as solved in some sense that's really
important now another thing is using
this this epigraph idea I can always
write a convex optimization problem in
this form so minimize T so that F of 0
minus f of T and this is sort of called
the epigraph transformation so if you
have a convex function this is basically
the epigraph the FF of f of X is less
than equal to T and I'm going to use
that in transformations we do with these
problems that gets used all the time so
then I have these so basically a linear
objective function and linear equality
constraints are ubiquitous so I'll be
mostly talking about things with linear
objective functions or I'll translate to
something with a linear objective
function
okay so basically it's all about cones
okay
now I would have preferred to use dan
Aykroyd and Gilda Radner than myself but
I wasn't sure about the copyright for
that so so I did this and also people
have said my appearance has been
changing slightly since I started
working on this project so I thought I
might as well show you okay so the the
particular cones we're gonna be talking
about are what what we'll call convex
proper cones so a cone is a set if you
have for any theta positive if X is in
the set theta X is also in the set so
it's basically kind of what you think of
as a you know the classic the classic
cone shape now a convex cone is a cone
that also satisfies convexity now this
is written in a slightly different form
because I'm taking advantage of the the
theta X term but basically any
combination for two theta is greater
than zero has to also be in the coin you
know a proper cone has a non-empty
interior so amazingly has to be full
dimensional as set and it also has to be
it has to be pointed namely that if you
have a set that's both in the cone and
and at minus X is also in the cone then
that that element has to be zero and
that's the point the point of the let me
show you a couple of pictures this is
this is our classic cone the one we
probably all think about okay so that's
that's a cone you can see I start here I
multiply by any multiple positive
multiple it's always going to be in the
cone and any two combinations will also
be in the in the cone and this is
actually one of the cones we'll be using
to do to map to the convex optimization
for here is something that is a cone but
it's not a proper cone okay because it
it it is full dimensional but it has
this this thing here so there's no there
so I can I can I can have I can have
this value I can have this value and my
this value they're both in the set but
they're not the same thing so it's not
pointed it has to be pointed in all the
dimensions okay so here are some common
cones that we're gonna be we're gonna be
doing with so one at this
the first one is often called the
positive orphan cone as well the norm
cone is often called the second word
cone and the semi definite cone and then
these are a little bit and a huge number
of problems I mean there's a huge number
of papers that show how you can map
different problems into those first
three cones there are some more papers
that show you how to do these other
cones but the first three are very
common and and cover a huge wide set of
application classes okay so now let's
talk about something we can do with
cones so suppose we have a proper cone
then you can define a partial order
based on membership in that cone and
this is this is as follows and this is
it's a little hard to see in these fonts
that we have now I'll eventually have a
good character for that but we have X is
less than or equal to and the by the
cone order Y if and only if Y minus X is
in the cone and the grey isn't equal is
basically the same thing with the assign
reversed so that that sort of sets up a
partial order so and we've actually set
this these are these are going to be
important toward don't worry about the
messages those I do it shouldn't be
there but we have we have commands
called cone less equal and cone greater
equal that allow you to to specify these
things and you can world ultimately once
this development version comes out
you'll be able to use that curvy equal
to indicate that as well which will be
which will be tighter and neater so the
two really frequent cases are the
non-negative cone and the semi definite
cone and they're quite distinguishable
because this is for vectors this is for
matrices so we can actually you can
specify those without the actual cone
given and we'll figure out which one you
actually mean so these actually evaluate
if we have things numerical so suppose I
set up a set of random real and I check
to see if it's con greater than equal
that means all elements are positive
okay now 0 is a special case so so this
is this doesn't fit into the definition
because this is a scaler not a vector
however if I add you know plus zero so
when I make that right-hand side a
vector then it evaluates and that's now
false because not all elements are
greater than 0.1 so it's that's element
wise comparison this is actually a
really fast way to evaluate that if you
need to do that for other reasons in
optimization so we can set up a matrix
I'm to set up a Kronecker product of two
to the vectors okay that is true that
evaluates to true so that means that MX
should be a possum a positive semi
definite matrix because without the the
cone its interprets a matrix is
interpreted as semi definite cone so we
can check well not quite okay I mean
actually theoretically if I take a
product two matrices it should be
positive but because of numerical error
the eigenvalues come out a little bit
negative and so when we actually do this
there's some tolerance included and it's
sort of the same tolerance since
included in this command it actually
works by using this command positive
semi definite matrix so there's always
remember when we're talking about these
things there's always a little bit of
tolerance tolerance involved okay so now
let's talk about another class of
optimization which I'm going to call
conic optimization okay and this is a
subclass of convex optimization but it's
ones particularly useful because we can
map problems into this and use features
of these cones to actually put up put
together solvers and solve the problem
so this is kind of the set that's
actually a solved problem so we're going
to have a linear function again that
represents any combat problem okay but
we're going to have F
mappings okay so a 1 X dot B has to be
in some cone which I'll call k1 and so
on and so forth so I have n cones and I
have the linear equality constraints
which goes with the convex part so I
have n cones okay and these are proper
cones X's vectors and so on and so forth
and basically so the whole set but I'm
thinking you know you could you can you
can combine cones so this could actually
be written as a single inequality over
the tensor product of all those cones so
it's a cone so it turns out that linear
optimization or linear programming it's
just a special case of this okay so it's
it's a 1 X dot b1 is and I'm using a
cone greater than equal and the cone
here is the non-negative cone of size n
where N and n is the number of
inequality constraints I have the
Equality constraints and so that's now
there's other standard there's this is
this is this is the way that Boyd and a
few authors write the conic problem
there's another standard way of writing
it that's that involves the X being in
the kkona it's always just as it's
possible to write to linear programming
you've probably gone through this
exercise at some point where you will
write so all the variables have
positivity constraints and stuff like
that and it's a bit of a pain in the
rear do that but it is possible and it's
possible for these as well there's also
a dual form I just don't have time to
talk about the dual forms but those are
actually very important in solving and
getting sensitivity and various things
like that so in another way yet I'll
just mention to express the conic
problem is this so instead of writing as
inequalities the equivalent expressions
are that this set so this affine mapping
of X has to be in cone one and so on and
so forth so it's element wise and that's
going to be important in what we're
going to I'm going to set up as the
canonicalization switch I'm going to
call which we're going to Jose help me
find this name we call it cone
transformation now it's probably not the
right name so if you can think of a
better name
you'll let me know but basically the
idea is we want us we want to say so
that's the set of X such that ax plus B
is in some cone okay so let's set up
I'll show you an example so I have this
set and this is actually it this is a
set okay so I can actually plot it so
this one it's the non-negative cone if
you think about it I've actually got
three inequality constraints so I have X
X X is greater than equal to 0 y is
greater than equals 0 and minus X minus
y is greater than equal to 2 okay and it
turns out to be this this polyhedron in
fact the the set of affine constraints
of the non-negative cones are the
polyhedra
it's the polyhedral cone so so that's a
common thing okay another way to look at
this is equipment to a dot X plus B it's
greater than 0 so these are the things
that have to be greater than 0 and of
course again maps to this maps to this
triangle I could plot that and I get
exactly the same plot okay so let's look
at so now what I've done in in this is
this is sort of this is not an eleven
point two yet or even a lesson you know
but it's a it's a prototype command
which I've called conic optimization so
I can set the vector for the linear
function so this basically means minus X
minus y I'm thinking of two variables so
as before and I can just call X manas
conic optimization so what it does is it
does the optimization over that set
which is defined by those cone
transformations and I get a result so
let's look at the rest of the result and
see if it makes sense
and sure enough because minus X minus y
basically I maximize in linear function
going in this direction there they can
minimize in going this direction that's
gonna have the biggest sum of x and y so
that's a simple linear programming
problem so now let's make another
example with a different cone that's a
little bit more interesting potentially
okay so I'm gonna set up a disk okay
this is actually another representation
of a disk
okay let's plot it and see okay and I
don't have time to go and explain
exactly how that
she looks is the disk but if you do the
mapping you'll see that it is and now I
can do something like this Connor
conversation of see the same see in the
disk and sure enough it comes up with
square root of 2 over square root of 2
because if the linear function is
decreasing this way the maximum the
minimum value is going to be is gonna be
there so now let's do a and again this
norm cone for example can represent a
huge number of sets I'm gonna show you
so this is the same I'm just put in a
random matrix instead of the one I chose
to represent the disk and I've got all
these sets represented and I get
something different every time so you've
got things like tubes and you know weird
parabolas and so on and so forth so so
there's a lot the conversions in it just
by the the norm cone sets ok so now
let's look at the more interesting
problem which is a so let's take that
first set which is the triangle in the
disk and do conic optimization over that
now I get a result so what does that
actually look like it's this ok but
notice I did a manipulate so as I change
the direction this is changing the
direction the linear function by the
locator it goes on different parts of
the disc and here notice it jumps
because along the line it's completely
it's completely indifferent I mean these
are all these these are all going to
have the same minimum values these are
outside the set but along here it makes
a difference where you chose so that's
why it jumps in that weird way ok so
let's look at the idea of a convex
modelling so I've set up this is sort of
a very prototype command which is
actually from I debugging I can write
out so you're not I don't think you're
going to want to construct these cone
transformations on your own I've sort of
figured how to do it because I've been
working with this stuff for a few months
but it's it's it's hard going probably
what you'll want to do is solve the
equivalent problems which might look
like this so so you want to minimize
this and so what the other part of what
working on it so we're working on this
canonicalization that gets us to the
solvers we're also working on something
that we're
from problems like this okay to get to
conic optimization problems that we're
going to be able to solve so this has an
input form okay and I can write this and
sort of the command that I put together
is a prototype and eventually what this
will be is this will just be in fine
minimum and then minimize you'll just be
able to use those and take advantage of
all this stuff but for now we've got
this development version so this is this
command which I call convex minimize
okay and it solves that problem and it
gives me that gives me essentially the
same answer but actually interestingly
enough it's a slightly different answer
okay so these and the only difference
between those two inputs is I have the
inactive norm and the norm and I'm going
to use that example to kind of go
through the process we're going from a
problem in terms of inequalities to get
to the conic optimization problem so
I'll use use that sort of as a platform
to explain so I've set up this thing
I've called minimization problem which
allows you to input a problem the idea
of that is to have a structure it's sort
of like an indie solve state data thing
where we can do changes and
transformations and eventually get the
problem into the form where we want to
solve it okay so this is what the one
with the evaluated norm so norm
evaluates symbolically which is our
which is the reason for the difference
so what I'm going to do I've got a
function I also called transform problem
what it does is it transforms that into
a form that can be recognizable okay to
the to the things that actually make the
conic the conic mappings so it takes
away it does this square root by
something called a monotone
transformation because square root is a
monotone function since the other side
is just a constant I can get rid of the
square root ABS of x squared is just X
so I are just x squared so I can get rid
of that and so now I get with a
quadratic function so now I have a
mapping from a quadratic function that
works like this so I have to map a
quadratic function a quadratic function
can always be remembered by represented
by two second order constraint a general
rule works like this so if I take
if I take a function XY s minus T over
to daughter with itself and I take s
plus T over to that comes out to x
squared plus y squared minus s s T
that's the so-called rotated
second-order cone so I can create
basically if I have something like this
and create a one longer second-order
cone that's going to do that so I end up
with again not time to do this with this
representation of the disk and just to
convince you that this is the same thing
I'll plot it sure enough it's just the
disk so it's the same thing but it's a
different representation and when the
numerical methods actually work with
that different representation they get
slightly different results and that
explains the difference of results so
the the transformations in mapping can
make a but that I think gives you an
idea of what the what's going on with
the mapping okay so we're getting short
on time with a couple more examples to
show you so this is a semi definite
example some using the the modeling
thing so this is idea you've got a bunch
of matrices and you take a 0 plus a 1 X
plus a 2 X you want to find values of
the the vector X to do various things so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
and choose a combination of matrices at
X's so that I can combine this a 0 and a
1 to minimize the spectral norm or the
the 2 norm of that okay so I don't and
I'm using a technique which is very
common with a semi definite program is
using the short compliments and so one
thing I want you to notice is that I've
entered these are this is a matrix this
is a matrix that I've entered this as a
block matrix and the processing
automatically recognizes that another
thing the processing is doing and I can
say I want this vector to be I want this
ax to be a vector of length K which in
this case is 2 so I can just enter that
in solvent it finds a solution and now
let's look at the plot of that and
what's interesting about this plot is
yes it is actually the minimum but
notice this has us crease and dimples so
it's it's not actually
smooth or continuous so let's I can do a
bigger problem that generalizes let me
do one more example to show you sort of
the extent of the transformation stuff
okay so this is a geometric programming
problem basically I'm trying to maximize
the volume of a box that satisfies the
thing so the volume of a box I've taken
one over to make it a minimization
problem everything is positive I can
call this transform problem and here
it's transformed everything to
Exponential's
so this problem actually as posed is not
convex but under a transformation D
equals log of D I've kept the variables
the same it does become convex with the
exponential function because it's
convexed and then I can actually solve
this problem by that and I get the
minimum my box well the problem is to do
that convex transformation to exit
everything has to be positive so that's
a trick for this particular sort of
problem that's a good question
okay so that's that I'm gonna skip this
example which is I knew I wouldn't have
time for anyway so I'm pretty close so
so basically the summary is automation
over convex sets provides a framework
that brings potentially difficult
problems into reach there are other
optimization frameworks existing today
such as CVX and japhet but I think the
Wolfram language because we can do these
transformations so nicely with our
symbolic stuff we've got a huge
potential to put together something
you're very nice and very automatic and
here are some new functions I'll just
let you look at that that'll be coming
down the pike some time and some changes
to existing functions so given that we
have a couple of seconds for questions
okay good enough
you